bro so i've never done like uh hard
drugs i've never done coconut and nah
you'd have to do the line never no i
ain't never treated a lot i would tell
you i don't give a [ __ ] are you from
that era bro listen buddy never in my
life my whole family's dope fiends i've
been scared of drugs my whole life you
from a z
trust me that's where that [ __ ] comes
and meth and all that yeah arizona's
like the meth capital fat and all that
anyway not fetty fetty
and az is crazy listen they smoke it out
there [ __ ] popping it and [ __ ] they
smoke confetti
they're like [ __ ] it we're just gonna
let it ride
it's crazy if you know him you've never
talked to molly no eat peel i've never
i've only smoked weed and done shrooms
never sir
never
i swear to god
bro when i tell you my family are drug
addicts in and out of prison my whole
life how you how are you all right
listen how you avoid all that but tamper
with shrooms
i barely started saying restrooms like
two years ago all right well who put you
on one of the homies joe rogan man joe
watching the joe rogan podcast all he
does is talk about how his life changed
mike tyson's podcast mike tyson started
doing psychedelics changed his life for
real yeah
mike tyson be smoking the toad though
what's that dmt
oh no nothing about it i'm asleep
so mike tyson slate what's that so mike
tyson his whole life changed when he
started smoking dmt
like you know how like tyson is like
real well measured now he's like really
like spiritually whole most definitely
um so dmt is
uh the chemical that your body
produces it's this what the [ __ ] is the
name of this gland
when you when you're born and when you
die your body produces a chemical called
dmt
there's a frog
that sweats natural dmt it's located in
arizona actually and in costa rica
and people will sweat the frog out
and then they'll freebase
the sweat
you do it with a crack pipe so it's real
crack head-ish
[Laughter]
[ __ ] smoke is frog sweat so if you ever
hear if you ever hear mike tyson talking
about
no so if you ever hear mike tyson
talking about uh
smoking what you do like put a nug a
weed in there with the frog and just no
rubber nugget weed on it nah you just
[ __ ] it like dries up and it gets
hard
and then you [ __ ] smoke it
that's crazy right dm no it's dmt it's
supposed to be it's supposed to be
amazing i'm gonna try it one day all
right but you've been tweaking on the
podcast and you like let me [ __ ] around
with some shrooms and you tamper with
them and that [ __ ] was just enlightened
yeah
yeah for sure
yeah now i never did side effects no i
mean i mean you can have it depends on
how much you eat you might have a
interesting night but outside of that
you can wake up the next day and be all
right
[ __ ] i don't know you know when i was a
kid i found crack in my dad's drawer
that was rough it was around the same it
was around the exact same time i was
listening to ghetto dope by master p and
i was like [ __ ]
this that ghetto this this [ __ ]
masterpiece
my best friend ramses
found that [ __ ] and we're like shout out
to master p every time [ __ ] ask me my
favorite rappers i never mentioned blood
but only b that was one of the first
[ __ ] bro that i really me too no limit
bro
i had to fake no limit chain straight up
i had all them all them
no limits
i could never afford no limit clothing
it was always too expensive you watched
all this movies man bout about it
he played in the nba
ghetto dope's one of my [ __ ] most
important albums of my life that orange
[ __ ] case remember it was orange it
was like all the cases were plastic and
colorful except the shocker mama i went
to the movie theater to see how i got
the hook up i got the hookup was so fire
crazy so good people don't talk about
that [ __ ] that was a good ass movie
yeah he was a man masterpiece a [ __ ]
legend sure him uh and then who was a
man i remember when i was a kid i used
to [ __ ] jerk off to that girl
mercedes album cover she had an album
called rear end she was bent over on
that [ __ ]
you remember that album
that [ __ ] said mercedes
you remember the no the chick on no
limit i remember the chick on no limit
hold on no not mia x not me and met x
that's what i was thinking of mia x now
i gotta show you because you're gonna
see that x is kind of chubby yeah she
wasn't the one to jerk to for sure
unless you're into the bb dubs you know
what i mean
mia x looks like she'll whip up some
fire fire ass food though
crazy and no limit